hoş geldiniz
oyun deyince
aklınıza hangi kelime geliyor ya da
aklınıza ne tür fikirler geliyor Bu
arada seyirciyle ben ya da
öğrencilerimle genelde etkileşim
içerisinde olmayı çok seven biri olarak
fikirleri buradan sesli olarak
alabilirim açıkçası Çünkü öyle bir
kelime düşünün ki
Türkçede dilimize en fazla üzerine anlam
yüklemiş Kelime oyun
Aslında tanımı çok basit değil mi
yapay bir çatışma gerekiyor
oynayanlar reflekslerini yeteneklerini
zekalarını kullanarak ulaşılabilir
puanlanabilir eğlenceli ve öğretici bir
sonucu ulaştıkları etkinlik olarak oyunu
söylüyoruz ama şöyle bir bakarsak
Aslında oyun dilimize biraz daha yakın
sağına doğru giderseniz negatif olarak
da
kazanmış işte Oyunbaz oyun çevirmek oyun
etmek oynaşmak oyuna getirmek sürekli
bir negatiflik o yüzden biz oyun
tasarımcılarına oyun yapıyorum dediğimiz
zaman her zaman bir negatif anlam sanki
kötü bir şey yapıyormuşuz gibi bir
fiyata kapılıyorlar
[Alkış]
şu konuda çok şanssızım Ne iş
yapıyorsun diye sorduklarında arkamda
böyle bir ekran gösteremeyecek kadar
şanssızın Çünkü
üniversitede Evet Bölüm Başkanlığı Evet
oyunları inceleyen alan demek Evet
Yönetmenlik yapıyorum Evet fotoğraf
çekiyorum ama günün sonunda bunları
toparlarsak Evet burada Sanat Galerisi
vesaire Aslında ben bir hikaye
anlatıcısıyım
fakat hikaye anlatırken klasik
metotlarla yetinmeyen ve
yeni metotlar yeni teknolojileri
kullanmak için can atan bir insanım
Çünkü ben çocukluğumu hatırlıyorum
bulmacalar çizen işte illüzyon yapıp
arkadaşlarımın o şaşırma ifadesini
görmek isteyen bir çocuktum yani
seyircinin veya işte karşındaki kişinin
şaşırma ifadesi beni gerçekten çok mutlu
ediyordu o yüzden
bugüne kadar geldiğimde
farklı alanlarda her zaman seyirciyi
şaşırtmak için bir yeni yöntemler
aramaya çalıştım
seyirciyi şaşırtmak istiyorsanız
seyircine E tabii ki insan her zaman
homosyon Prensi duyduk düşünen insan
homofoben neydi Aslında imalat yapan hem
alet edevat üreten insan homosyon neydi
sosyalleşen insan fakat orada bir homolü
dersi var ki biz ona oyun oynayan insan
diyoruz bir insanın oyun oynayabilme
becerisini kazanabilmesi için düşünmesi
bir şeyi icat etmesi tasarlaması
sosyalleşmesi bir toplum oluşturulması
ve bunu gerçekten hayata geçirilmesi
gerekiyor
O yüzden bu noktada oyun çok
antropolojik bir şey çünkü oyunlara
baktığımız zaman Aslında insanlık
tarihini incelediğinizde oyunları saf
dışı bırakırsanız
sosyolojik olarak psikolojik olarak
Toplumsal olarak her zaman eksik bilgiye
ulaşırsınız Mesela ben burada
seyircileri şunu sormak istiyorum
aranızda tavla oynamayı bilen var mı
[Alkış]
aranızda Santranç Oynamayı bilen var mı
Eller gerçekten yükseliyor Evet kova
biraz kapsamlı bir oyun ama uzak doğuda
Üniversitesi olan yüksek lisansını
okuyabildiğiniz televizyon kanalı olan
Çin'de Japonya'da Kore'de ve Profesör
oyuncu olabileceğiniz bir oyun ve 4000
yıldır oynanıyor ve kuralları günümüzde
hiç değiştirilmemiş Yani aslında
baktığınız zaman Uzak Doğu kültürünü
günümüze kadar nasıl safkan bir şekilde
Taşıyıcı taşıdığının en kapsamlı örneği
Evet Satrançta tavlada Eller kalktı
oyunu biliyorsunuz Peki mangala desem
kaç kişi oynamayı biliyor
[Alkış]
şu an en sayısı o kadar az ki
mangala Aslında 4000 yıllık
bizim Türk oyunumuz
ama deminki yükselen ellere baktığında
tavla veya Satrançta baktığımız zaman
bilinen sayısıyla kendi oyunumuzu bilime
sayısı o kadar düşük ki arasındaki Oran
Aslında deminki antropolojiye baktığımız
zaman Neyi göreceğiz kendi uyduğunu bile
bilmeyen kendi hikayesini de bilmez
oyunun kurallarını bilmeyen
hikayesini anlatma metotlarında
geliştiremez o yüzden biz kendi
toplumumuzdaki oyunu kurallarına hakim
olmuyoruz bir dili üstüne Üstün mangala
günümüze kadar kuralları taşımamışız
taşıyamamışız unutulmuş şu an günümüz
olarak güncelle oynanan mangalayı
tahminen yorumda bir oyun tasarımı
haline getirmişiz düşünün Türk oyunu
orijinal bir Türk oyunu ama günümüze
kadar getirememişiz
Şimdi ben sizi izliyorum Siz ekrana
bakıyorsunuz
hiç tepki vermediniz
Bu neydi
lumial Kardeşler kamerayı icat ettiği
zaman ilk trenin garaj girişi sahnesi ve
bunu gösteriyorlar seyirciler karşısında
Şu an hiç tepki vermediniz benim gibi
seyircisine Reaksiyon bekleyen bir
hikaye anlatıcısı için çok üzücü ama
bundan yaklaşık 120 yıl önce seyirciler
böyle bir tepki veriyordu
üstlerine geliyormuş gibi korkuyorlar
Çünkü niye ilk defa görüyorlar yanlış
bilinir Lumia Kardeşler motion picture
dediğimiz kamera icat ettiler ama onunla
bir hikaye anlatılabileceğini fark
edemediler burada görüntüde Vigo
filminden aldım milia'yı görüyorsunuz
Milliye bir illüzyonist illüzyonistin en
büyük şeyi nedir motivasyonu serisinden
Reaksiyon almak onu şaşırılmasını görmek
ondan haz almak Melih de bunu görüyor Ve
biliyorsunuz ki dünyadaki ilk kurmaca
hikaye anlatılan film neydi filmi icadı
Tabii ki yapan kişi Milliye yani demek
ki hikaye anlatma metodu ve teknikleri
ve teknolojileri insanlara belli bir
süre sonra
şaşırtmayı bırakıyor deminki gördüğü
hissini verdin tepkiyle seyircilerin
arasında bir fark var demek ki hareketli
görüntüler gerçek görüntülere baktığımız
zaman
Biz hikaye anlatma metotlarında yine
teknolojileri kullanmak bizim için çok
olası ama sinema salonlarına baktığımız
zaman hala
1895'teki metotlar kullanılıyor sadece
bir perde var Ve hala o büyük perden
şaşırmamız bekleniyor Ama biz şu an 2022
yılında bireyler olarak dokunmatik
ekranlarda filmler izleyen biri olarak
bizi şaşırtmak değil mi biraz daha
uğraşılması gereken bir şey bende sinema
okumuş insansız sinema yüksek lisanslı
sinema doktorası sinema bunun üzerine
araştırmalar yapmış birisi Ben
üniversitedeyken daha mezun olduğum
zaman onun üzerinde ödülüm vardı ama
yeni metodlar geliştirmek gibi bir
amacım da vardı
2015 yılında kontakt Games diye bir oyun
şirketi kurduk Aslında
deminki gördüğünüz gibi Gerçek dünya
Aslında şaşırtıyor ama anlatma metodları
ve teknolojilerini farklılaştırdığımız
zaman seyirci tekrardan şaşırabiliyor
burada
Kanuni görebilirsiniz
sinema okumuşum filmler çekiyorum dedim
ki video ile oyun dinamiklerini
birleştireceğim 3 kişiyle bir aile
yaptık ve ondan bir ay sonra
Apple Store'da 153 ülkede tüm dünyada
sergilendi Apple yılın oyunu seçti
ödülleri aldık bir anda oyun sektörüne
çok hızlı bir şekilde giriş yapmış olduk
Çünkü buradaki anahtar kelime özgünlüktü
Fikret kuşkan Ahmet Ümit gibi isimler
Haldun Boysan gibi isimlerle Aslında
baktığın zaman üçü de polisiyedir Çünkü
polisiye bulmaca mekaniklerini hikayenin
içerisinde Entegre edebileceğiniz en
güzel canavarlardan bir tanesi Aslında
buradaki mekanikler basit güvenlik
kamerasına şüphelileri bulmaya
çalıştığınız bir polisiye oyunu
oynuyorsunuz tamamen görüntüler gerçek
ama burada hikaye şekil veriyorsunuz
güvenlik kameralarını Siz buluyorsunuz
Yalan mı söylüyorlar doğru mu
söylüyorlar suçlular Siz bulmaya
çalışıyorsunuz seyirci işin içine dahil
etmeye çalıştım ve
yayıncıları biliyorsunuz televizyon
yayıncılarını Twitch yayıncılarını oyuna
oynarken Bunlar iki tane önemli Twitch
yayıncısı biliyorsunuz artık seyirciler
bir şeyi deneyimleyen izleyen kişiyi
izliyor artık o kadar şaşıramıyorlar ki
şaşıran bir insan görmeye daha muhtaçlar
benim oyunumdan bir sahnede ne kadar
şaşırdıklarını ben görüyorum Aslında
sanki Her seyircime bir kamera takmışım
gibi onları izliyormuşum gibi onları
dikizliyorum ve onların tepkilerini
görmek beni gerçekten yeteri kadar
motive ediyor
Ben üniversitede fotoğraf makinesi ile
Türkiye'de ilk uzun metraj filmi çeken
kişiyim bitirme projem olarak çekmiştim
ve görüntülere bakıyorsunuz bunu 14 yıl
önce vesaire Aslında fotoğraf makinesi
için çok enteresan bir kavram Ama bakın
kalem kullanmak yazarlık gibi olarak
bahsetmiyorum yeni teknolojiler yeni
metotlar fotoğraf makinesi film yapmak o
kadar zorluklar yepyeni metotlar
geliştiriyor Ve ben bunu insanlarla
paylaşmak istedim ve 2014 yılında
interaktif ve ücretsiz bir şekilde nasıl
film yapabilirsiniz ses kurgu senaryo
nasıl yazılır Ee bir interaktif kitap
yazdım ve bu İngilizce şekilde
satışına çıkardım Çünkü Nedenini
bilmediğim bir şekilde bilgilerimi
insanlarla paylaşmayı çok seviyorum ve
bundan Aslında çok motif alıyorum
Özellikle bu yüzden hocalık yapıyorum
İstanbul
2015 yılında bu kadar Turkcell
getirdikten sonra pire Müzesi Burası
video sanatı olarak sergiledik ve
seyircilerine olan ki reaksiyonlarını o
anki İşte benim hikayemle beraber nasıl
entegre oluyorlar bunun heyecanını
yaşamış oldum baktığın zaman disiplinler
arası bir şey video sanatı Pera
Müzesi'nde San francisco'da yeni mdfin
Festivali ödülü alıyor orada oyun
sanattır diye Ailesi skalaları açıyor 11
dile çıkıyor tüm dünya ile
kavuşuyorsunuz Çünkü sinema okuyanlar
bilir Sinema filmlerini artık insanlara
ulaştırmanın yöntemleri çok azaldı ve
demin söylediğim gibi seyircinin artık
şaşırılması çok azaldı bir noktada da
dokunmatik bir ekranda film izliyorsanız
artık o filme dokunmak istiyorsunuz
seyirci olarak o filmin etkileşime
geçmek istiyorsunuz Bu benim için önemli
motivasyonlardan bir tanesiydi ama yetti
mi yetmedi teknoloji gelişiyor teknoloji
geliştikçe Benim de hikaye anlatma
motivasyonum değişiyor mesela IOS Sky
Biraz önce gösterdim gökyüzünün gözleri
olarak ikinci oyunumda bir flashback
sahnesi Evet VR visu kamerası Evet işte
gözlükler Bunlar teknolojiler gelişiyor
ama deminki Lumia Kardeşler örneği gibi
onlar sadece kamerayı Buluyor kendi
röportajlarına bile şunu diyorlar
sinemanı diye bir şey olabileceğinin
farkında bile değildik Onun gibi yani
eğer teknolojisi çıkıyor ama hikaye
hikayesi entegre etmek bir flashback
sahnesi onun içerisinde onu hatırlamaya
çalışmak vesaire tamamen yine hikaye
anlatıcısın modunda yetti mi yetmedi
ondan sonra yeni oyunlarım çekerken Ee
arttırılmış gerçeklik teknolojisi ve
cihazlar teknolojisinin geliştirildi hem
de artırılmış teknolojilerle artırılmış
gerçeklik teknolojileriyle seyircimi
polisi ortamda kendi evinde Olay yeri
inceleme yapabilmesini ve hikayeye yön
vermesini hikaye bulunmasını amaçladım
bu noktada seyirciyle sürekli bir
etkileşim içinde olmak deminki en
baştaki söylediğim şey onları Sürekli
şaşırtmak şaşırtmanın yeni yöntemlerini
aramakla doğrudan bağlantılı hale geldi
silikonda Londra'da çektiğim O deminki
Bu arada olay yeri incelemede yatan kişi
Game Of thrones'ta White Wall
canlandıran Rose
hala
seyirciyi şaşırtıyorsanız sizin
projenizde yer almak isteyen insanları
da şaşırtıyorsunuz ve projenize dahil
ediyorsunuz Burada da eee bir Maktül Biz
polisiz Tabii bilgisayar görüntülerini
inceliyoruz şüpheli bir şeyler arıyoruz
oyununun içerisinde sanki Sherlock
holmesesine modern bir şeyler yapalım
Londra sokaklarını fotoğraflar çekmiş
onu ben şüpheli bir şeyler arıyoruz
aslında bir sokak fotoğrafçılısı sergin
Yani aslında kendi işlerimi Kendi
görüntülerimi sergilerken bile sadece
sanat galerilerinde sınırlı kalmaman
gerektiğini kendi oyunumun içerisinde
bile bir sanat galerisi
oluşturabileceğim ve işlerim
sergileyebileceğimi gösteren metotlar
geliştirdim Bu arada ben tabii ki
gerçekten ilham alıyorum benim oyun
motorum Aslında Gerçek dünya fotoğraf da
çekerken ne oluyor bu noktada Şöyle
devam edelim cep telefonlarına Liar Eee
sensörler lazer tarama teknolojileri
gelişiyor Ben mesela fotoğrafçılığı işte
3 boyutlu 360 derece tarama Yeri geldiği
zaman bir fotoğrafımı Sadece düz bir
zemine basmakla yetinmeyip onu daha
farklı metotlarda geliştirme tarzında
bir yaklaşımda bulunuyorum kendimi
geliştirmek zorundayım
Çünkü seyirci şaşırtmak zorundayım Ama
bu bana aynı zamanda ne sağlıyor
yeni alan açmayı sağlıyor değil mi Ben
hikaye anlatırken hikaye anlatıcılığı
sırasında yani sadece kısır bir
döngüdeki klasik yöntemlerle hikaye
anlatmaya çalışırsam o zaman Ne olur
benim hikayelerimi dinleyebilecek insan
sayısı görebilecek insan sayısı azalır
Ya ben film çekeceğim ama sineması
salonlarına Nasıl gireceğim işte ben
sana ortamlarda işte sosyal mecralarda
işlerimin nasıl yayınlayacağım nasıl
kabul ettireceğim vesaire bunlarla
uğraşmak sizi yoruyor mu ama anlatacak
hikayeniz mi var O zaman bize benim
yaptığım gibi kendimi de yeni sektörler
yeni alanlar açmak bu noktada en motive
edici şeylerden bir tanesi Çünkü
anlatacak bir hikayeniz varsa
emin olun Onu anlatacak bir teknoloji de
var ve onu da seyircisi var
Ayvalık Küçükköy'de Kız kardeşim
simaydinç ile beraber bir sanat galerisi
ağırlık ve Orada hem sanat genç
sanatçıları destekliyoruz hem de Ayvalık
küçükköy'deki köyümüzün minikkilerini bu
tarzda yeni alanlar açabilmesi yeni
teknolojileri kullanması için ilham
olmak adına bu eğitimleri onlarla
paylaşıyoruz Çünkü
dediğim gibi paylaştıkça
ilham alırsınız ilham aldıkça alana
açarsınız Teşekkürler sağ olun
[Müzik]